it's honor to be here with you all on
this day to thank our veterans to honor
their sacrifices many care the physical
wounds of War almost all carry the
usable scars they join the service whole
and often leave pieces of themselves in
these distant lands yet they would never
leave a fallen brother behind and they
will drive on to complete the mission no
matter what an Army Ranger chooses this
he volunteers for it fully knowing the
hazards of his chosen profession it's
not for the money he makes not much more
than if he chose a regular nine to five
non-combat job it's not for the benefits
you get the same if you chose a less
hazardous specialty
it's not for the work-life balance he
trains for seven months and deploys for
four months every year giving up time
with his family and loved ones
so why does he do it he does it from the
man's his left hand is right to protect
his loved ones back home
for all of us civilians Stateside right
now
regardless of whether you support him or
not he's willing to sacrifice everything
for you
many have given that ultimate sacrifice
and may they never be forgotten
to all the veterans we've served thank
you for your sacrifices you've made and
continue to make
you have given this country a privilege
that is beyond payment
we honor you for that today and every
day thank you
[Applause]